(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together six brides to be.
- Hi, my name's Jaclyn
and I'm getting married.
- Hi, I'm Savanna and I'm getting married.
- Hi, my name is Heather
and I'm getting married.
- Hi, my name is Rachel
- Hi, my name is Aimee
and I'm getting married.
- Hi, I'm Tatyanna and
I'm getting married.
- [Narrator] One of them is a divorcee.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
(upbeat music)
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the odd one out.
- Cheers!
(women laugh)
- So when are you guys getting married?
- We're getting married 11/11/22.
- Oh cute, that's cute.
- Nice!
- August 20th for us.
- We actually just decided we would like a
September wedding, in 2024.
- I'm getting married next month,
on the 22nd.
- Oh wow.
- Oh my gosh, congratulations!
(women laugh)
- So I don't have a
wedding date set yet just
cuz my fiance is in nursing school.
So, he'll be done in August.
So sometime, probably next year.
- Yeah.
- Is when the date potentially will be.
Yeah.
- When you're engaged,
like the first thing
you wanna do is start
planning your wedding.
How are your wedding preparation's going?
- Pretty good so far,
we actually have a destination wedding.
We're getting married in Minnesota so...
- Are you from Minnesota?
- He is.
I'm from Wisconsin,
so, my family's gonna drive over.
- We actually wanted to
do a destination wedding.
However, a lot of our family
members can't actually travel.
So, we decided on doing a very
traditional Mexican wedding.
- Me and my fiance talked
about potentially doing something
really small, whether it's
like a celebration in someone's
backyard or just eloping.
I think the older I get,
the more realistic I wanna
become about my finances.
- Totally!
- Cause it's so expensive.
- Yeah.
- How many people are you
guys hoping to invite?
- A hundred or less.
- Yeah, we have very similar.
- Oh really?
- Well I have a really big family.
- Yeah.
- And she has a really big family,
so, we're kind of hoping
for it to be less than 200.
- Did you guys know the
proposal was coming?
- No, not at all.
(women laugh)
- No, I mean I kept him
sending her hints, you know
she did it in a completely weird way.
(women laugh)
- She basically---
(bell rings)
- I guess I just voted Savanna
cuz we didn't really get
much chances to talk.
So I didn't really get to hear her story.
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sound)
- I think people were suspicious
of me because I wasn't
like talking enough.
Maybe, it was like more, not what I said
but more of like what
I didn't say, you know?
- Okay. I feel like we
should dive into details
cuz I feel like that's kind
of the first thing you forget
if like your wedding was a long time ago.
- Yeah.
- What was the last vendor
you guys locked down?
Mine was our DJ.
- Well, I'm still kind of
planning, but I already went to
see a couple of venues
that I am interested in
and I have my eye on one
and that's in Chino Hills.
It's a beautiful hacienda with like,
I dunno, if you guys seen the
horse stables and all that.
- [Jaclyn] Every time
Heather asked a question
Aimee would answer first.
So it would skip over me.
So, maybe she's trying to just
like quickly answer first.
- I like reached out
to a few photographers
through Instagram but the people
that I was interested in aren't available.
So I gotta kind of figure that out.
- How was your guys engagement?
- Just engagement so far?
- Like the proposal or?
- Yeah, just a proposal.
- Mine was unexpected.
I mean, we had talked about marriage
but I wasn't sure when or if it was coming
but we went to Yosemite in
September for the weekend
and he proposed like at
the beginning of the trip
at the base of half dome it
was very, it was perfect.
- Beautiful.
- Yeah. Mine was actually in Utah.
I do, I'm an avid hiker.
So, he took me on a hike that
I really wanted to go to.
It's called Lake Blanche.
And she proposed to me
basically after the hike
which was horrible because
I was like sweating.
I looked horrible.
So yeah, she was, yeah.
- I heard Amy slip up pronouns a bit
but even then I wasn't quite sure
because I wasn't sure if her
fiance had maybe transitioned
and she was getting used
to the new pronouns.
- Well, I went to a
work Secret Santa party.
And so then I came home that night.
We have a very small apartment
so, there was like notes on the ground.
So, then I'm following the
notes to our little couch
in the corner and then he loves memes
and then it ends with
like a Mike Wazowski meme,
will you be my wife wazowski?
And then I turn and he's on
his knee and then I just cried.
- Aww.
- That's so cute.
(woman laughs)
(bell rings)
- She did have like a
little like she/he slip up.
- She's kind of more in
the middle area of things.
Look I don't know.
(laughs)
It was kind of a shot in
the dark the whole time.
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sound)
- Bye guys.
- Bye.
- Because I was talking so fast,
I did notice that I, you know
mispronounced my pronouns and
I was like, oh, I'm doomed.
That's it.
- [Host] Raise your hand,
if you think the mole is still
in the box and you would
like to continue the game.
Because you decided to continue the game.
We're gonna throw in a new rule.
Starting now, for every
time you vote someone out
who is not the mole,
the total prize money will be reduced.
- Okay. I'm curious what you
guys think about divorce.
- I'll go first,
Connor and I are having
a religious ceremony.
So, we definitely look at
marriage in a very spiritual way.
It sounds super obvious, but like
I don't want to get married
if I ever think that there's
divorce on the horizon.
- Yeah, same.
I guess when I say I do, I'm committed.
And so I don't judge
anyone who is divorced
but I do understand that
sometimes things happen.
Yeah.
- At least for myself,
and again, same as you, like
I know people that have gotten divorced
and I just don't want to
allow that to be part of it.
If like we're really trying to show people
Jesus love for them, so yeah.
- For sure.
- Let me put a spotlight on
me, but I work in bridal.
So, I'm actually a bridal stylist.
So, a lot of times I get brides come in,
who are actually like this
wasn't the best thing for me.
So now, this is my like rebirth.
So, I believe that some
people need the divorce to
pretty much figure out their next step.
But our end goal is to
stay together for forever.
- Is there any fears
that you guys have about
coming together in a marriage?
- So I feel like it's not a fear with us,
it's a fear like I wanna
have babies, but then it's
like money then it's like wedding money
and honeymoon money and like
just life, money overall.
- Right.
- So I feel like that's
always a concern, but like
I feel like, we're working it out together
so, we can figure it out together.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- In dating him, I've come to know him
as a person that I can trust.
And I believe that together
we're a really good pair and
that we work well on instill
conflicts that they do come up.
- She said she was in
the wedding industry.
And I thought, you know
if anyone can kind of make
their way through this
it'd be someone who's
surrounded by wedding stuff.
(upbeat music)
- Heather and Rachel were giving
off like big bridal, like excited energy.
So, then it just kind
of came down to Jaclyn.
(buzzer sound)
- I'm not like a really bubbly person.
It may be perceived as
someone who's not as, eager.
- [Host] Raise your hand.
If you think the mole is still in the box
and you would like to continue the game.
That's unanimous.
- Okay.
(women laugh softly)
- So the game is over.
If the lights turn green,
that means you have voted
the mole out and you all win.
However, if the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
(suspenseful music)
- Yay!
(women cheer)
- I like winning.
(laughs)
So, it's just fun.
- [Host] Will the mole
please reveal themselves,
in 3...
2...
1...
- Oh.
- Okay okay.
- Hi everyone.
(women laugh)
- What's your story?
- I was 20 years old when I got married.
My ex-husband was 10 years older than me.
I did it for the wrong reasons.
I did it for my family's acceptance.
They did not accept that I was gay.
They come from a very
traditional household where,
they have always believed
that once you're married,
that's it.
So to them, it was like an embarrassment.
And it made me feel like.
At the end of the day
this is my life.
This is who I am.
I'm still open to marriage.
I have a beautiful girlfriend
that I am very in love with.
And finally, my parents
are very accepting of it.
So hopefully, you know,
maybe I'll be the one getting engaged.
- Do you hear that?
(women laugh)
This is the biggest hint
drop I've ever seen.
(women laugh)
(bell rings)
- But you know,
congratulations to all of you.
You guys are gonna be beautiful brides.
I'm very excited for you guys.
- Thank you.
- Hopefully when I do it next,
it'll be for the right reasons
and with the right person.
- Okay. Unfortunately I do
gotta take some of that away.
- Oh I mean, not that much.
- It's okay.
- Woo! We did it!
(women laugh)
- Yes.
- This will just barely
cover some of the flowers.
- For the vendors!
- For the vendor.
(women laugh)